it looks beautiful behind you is this
thank you like your backyard what's
happening
back there yeah i'm at my grandma's
house right now and
it is so beautiful here so that's why
i'm here right now today ah
it's gorgeous as i have to say uh
i'm a big fan of yours from agt do you
think that people ever underestimate
your ability to sing because you're so
young
uh well um uh my my first uh
um contestant were was in ukraine and i
was like 10 years old there
and i always had like the right timbre
for
my voice that made my voice sound like
more major but uh in real life i'm not
really like
i i wasn't really good at walking skills
because i was just 10 years old and it
was my like
first year of singing of professionally
singing so
uh it was it is just my timbre that is
making my voice more major
uh and yeah i think um sometimes um
my looks um
i don't know may make uh other people
shocked because of my voice
because i'm i look really young and um
my voice is sounds really major so yeah
sometimes
people are shocked because of this oh
one of my favorite things
when you were on the show was just
seeing the judge's reactions every
single time
you say yeah it was it was really nice
to see that they were action for me too
how did being on the show
um change your life and your career you
know it
kind of introduced you to millions and
millions of people
um it was really shocking for me that um
a lot of people subscribed my channel my
instagram account
and i was literally so scared because
like when my
first video from audition uh was out
i was really nervous about my about my
life because i thought that people would
not like my voice
well not like my performance i was
really insecure at that time
and um it was just shocking for me that
uh i
i think my like followers really um
amount of my followers really grew up
and i'm really happy that
now i have a huge platform to share my
music to share my covers
and my content and i'm really really
grateful
for people who helped me to get there
because it was
a big experience for me that helped me
um
that helps me right now and being on the
show was just
so much fun but at the same time it was
really stressful for me
because at the finals round final round
i lost my voice before my performance
because i was really really nervous
before my performance because the song
is like really big and i didn't have a
lot of time to prepare it
so i was it was super stressful it was
actually the hardest
um project in my life uh yeah and
i'm really happy and proud of myself
that i made it and made it to the finals
so yeah my agency really changed my life
a lot and
i'm really happy that i had this
experience in my life
absolutely and now we're here
celebrating your
solo career and looking forward to your
solo music
how long have you been working on your
own stuff
um not really long because um i just
i i yeah just recorded the song that
will be out on 21st of may and uh
it is so it's absolutely new experience
for me because before
i just um like um took a part in
different competitions and just um was
growing up
as a vocalist and um yeah my
vocal skills really grew up on every
show uh but now
uh the new part of my life started uh
and
i'm really happy for people that helped
me uh and
yeah i'm really excited for my song that
will be out on
21st of may and i really hope that um
everyone will like it because i'm really
nervous but i'm sure that
in the future my songs will will get
better and better i hope so
you've mentioned a couple times that you
know you you get nervous and that's a
natural thing because
nerves come from when you really care
about something right like when you
really want something
to be good how do you yourself push past
that feeling of being nervous to be able
to perform the way you do
or record the song the way that you do
actually i don't think that i
i'm healthy nervous because sometimes
i'm just
uh almost dying before my performance
and then yeah even before um when i took
part in eurovision song
contest before the first performance
like
concert i was really scared i thought
that i
i can die just right before the stage
and i was clearly like i was about to
i don't know myself because um like i'm
always really
nervous before the stage and i don't
know how to fight this feeling uh
and i think only only after i start
singing
on the stage uh i become like
i lose this feeling of nervous and yeah
i'm starting
i'm starting being myself so i can i
don't know how to fight it
just start singing that's it you just
gotta fight it with song
it's the best way to do it right yes
okay so you do have this song coming out
like you used to tell us all about it
what's it about
uh so this song is about um love
i didn't think like about relationship
that ended
uh i didn't have a relationship in my
life but
i watched a lot of movies and uh read a
lot of books about it
and i'm a fan of like this stories like
this
when the relationship ended with breakup
so i that's why um i really love my song
because
the main the like the meaning of the
song is um
can relate a lot of teenagers can relate
to the song
uh so for me like the process of
recording of the song was really fun
because i'm
obsessed with the song and i hope that
everybody will be obsessed
with it with it too so um
i'm really happy that i have the song
right now and i will perform
the song on the stage because i love it
i hope that everybody loved it
that's awesome i'm really curious you
know what movies were the ones that you
watched that had you go oh yes
i understand heartbreak now like which
which ones were your favorites
um after i think
do you know about this movie i don't
know uh it is about a
love between a shy girl and bad boy
and actually uh after is one of my
favorite books
i read all of them so yeah that's why
i know how to how it feels to
be in a relationship and struggle with a
breakup
so yeah i know everything about it even
though i
didn't have a relationship with anybody
so yeah that's how i know
how it feels like that's what the movies
are for
so that we know
so given that you get nerves before you
perform
and before you record what was the
feeling you got when you first
heard the song back were you were you
happy with it
were you excited about the idea of
sharing it what did it feel like
at the beginning when i first heard of
this song
there was my voice it was like another
girl voice
and um i really liked the song but i
thought that i can sing it in another
way
and when i first heard my version of the
song when it like already already
like ended and they sent it to me i was
really happy because
um i i think that i changed
the song in a good way and now i
absolutely um know that
my fans will like it because i made
everything i did my best
to make this song the best song in my
life
so yeah and and you're still in school
right
yeah i'm in i'm like and the eighth
grade
and i'm an excellent student by the way
good well good that's it's important
yeah
what do what do all your friends in your
school think about
everything that you're doing and
everything that you've been through
i'm actually not communicating with my
classmates i don't have
a lot of friends i just have one friend
that that always supports me
she's like two years older than me so
she's like a mother to me like second
mother and
she always supports me and i'm really
happy that i have
her in my life because she makes my life
so much better and brighter and
i love her so much so yeah my family and
my friends
always support me and i'm really
grateful that i have been
i have them in my life are you
dedicating any songs to your friends
um no but
but i love i still love her because like
i don't know
how to write songs yet but i will learn
how to
so maybe in the future i will write a
song for her
maybe that'd be lovely swing of the
future where do you see yourself
in five years 10 years what's the goal
for you
now i'm starting really really hard to
go to the good university maybe in new
york or
in other country
and i don't know now i'm just starting
really really hard and learning english
and maybe after i will i will like
have a singing career i will be a lawyer
i really hope so because
like this is one of my like dream jobs
and
um now i'm starting to be a lawyer in
the future that's amazing
daniella the future is so bright for you
thank you i hope so
you